brian thank you for being here in person
so good to be here
isn't it nice to take it you left your
home and went someplace
to drive to just to get out it means so
much to me thank you
so you don't care about being here on
the show you just wanted to get out of
the house
that's primarily it and i have a list of
things i need to pick up at the store
now you've asked that i interview you
while you shop while you
pick up things at the grocery store well
it'll be as exciting as your other
episodes
zing you know i didn't come here to be
insulted by you wait a minute that's
exactly why i came here
uh we have so much to talk about first
this is a reunion of sorts because i
know you've worked with
the great andy richter before you got
andy you guys have worked together
we have a couple of few times yeah yeah
we did a movie together and then i was
in a
uh an episode of malcolm in the middle
right the movie was a
it was a an adult sex movie so we don't
usually talk about that one but
um but yeah he was terrific
well i've seen the movie four times yeah
you are
forgettable andy richter uh completely
forgettable he is
oh yeah he is an amazing amazing it no
was it
a movie called seeing other people is
this
uh from that movie uh i don't know what
this is from this is a still i was given
that is the two of you oh i think in
this one
andy was telling me about his sexual
prowess
and i uh i'm reacting and he's so
rolling
i just was doing that yeah you were just
doing that andy is so proud of working
with you that this
is his driver's license photo it's the
two of you it's
it's the only two-shot driver's license
photo
that exists i was gonna say from the
lighting of that you could tell they
could afford him and me
yeah uh as you can see we're being very
coveted safe here andy
you and i are uh more than six feet
apart and andy
i insist it'd be uh 65 feet away from me
it's a court
thing for some reason yeah the
restraining order was that was the
minimum